tim cook here tim cook
uh his salary is surprisingly low he and
14.8 million dollars in 2020 not
counting stock awards okay
uh 40 million dollar salary 2020
according to 2020 proxy statement that
apple filed with the sec cook earned a
base salary of three million dollars in
addition to 10 million
731 thousand dollars in incentives
awarded for his performance apple's
performance exceeded the target
performance goals
for net sales and operating income
leading to a total payout of 179
total payout opportunity for cooking
other apple executives
cook also received one million dollars
in other compensation for a total of
14.7 million dollars
that included seventeen thousand hundred
dollars into 401k contributions term
insurance life
payment and a hundred hundred fifteen
thousand dollar vacation payout
security expenses in the amount of four
hundred seventy thousand dollars four
hundred thirty two thousand dollars in
personal air travel expenses
apple requires cook to use a private
airplane for security reasons in 2019 he
took home eleven
and a half million dollars so that means
it's a raise however we looked at it
yesterday
over the course of 2020 cook's net worth
climbed to over
1 billion dollars overpaid or underpaid
uh he's probably either perfectly paid
or underpaid
he one thing the board turned him down
on he was negotiating he wanted to get a
new iphone 12 into those fancy pods they
couldn't afford it they're just too
expensive
they would not throw that into that
incentive package you know he should
create a ceo
school he should do one of those master
classes he
is really a great ceo if you ask me he
stays under the radar screen
doesn't get too political you know you
don't look at him you think he's radical
one way or another like some of these
other ceos
his parents live in the same house that
he grew up in in alabama
you know he's on the board of directors
of nike there's just a lot about a lot
about this guy that i don't like or that
i like about him here's a funny story
about tim
cook apple was trying to recruit him
these headhunters were reaching out to
him in the late 90s he hung up on him
he said he had one five-minute
conversation with steve jobs
came over there came running and never
left so it's interesting because he was
kind of
you know pretty successful in the tech
industry and they were trying to get him
he had no interest in it until he
had a conversation with jobs but this
was this was also when apple was
struggling because he came in and helped
with the manufacturing and the logistics
arm
but they were struggling so what he came
in and then obviously steve jobs did his
thing
and he convinced him that this would be
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity no
that's cool that's a good story
you just you look at tim cook you don't
think baller you don't think
self-serving you just think of really
solid i'm a big smart i've kept saying
i'm a big fan of him adam i mean he's
the ceo of the biggest
uh company in the world i mean what's
bigger than apple amazon
walmart what's bigger than those guys
market share it's competing at walmart's
not in the number but it's a
it's apple and it's amazon okay um
gay like like awesome you're the number
one ceo that's like
i mean no one ever talks about that but
like that's
for the gay community they should be
like open you know gay ceo fortune 100
gangster yep you know he's a billionaire
it's like
the salary whether he makes 10 million
dollars a year 20 million dollars or 14
or 17 it's like
irrelevant but the most important thing
that he is getting
is his 17 000 401k match that's that's
great for him congratulations i know
that's a big thing
what kind of life insurance coverage do
you think he's got they said term life
insurance
what do you think amount of coverage a
guy like that should have
100 million should have you're only
doing it for taxes by the way you know
yeah yeah
we just talked about that planning taxes
yeah 100 million
50 to 100 million bucks minimum if i was
him i'd have more but
you know you need to get it underwritten
but say how much 200
if listen to me you know there's not
enough life insurance to get for a rich
person get as much as you can get if you
can't get it get it
i'd probably get a quarter of a billion
dollars of life insurance if i'm here
but why term
why he has to do it yeah i would like
this term should have an iul of some
sort right i have a permanent type of an
insurance problem tim listen if you're
listening we've got a couple of life
agents out there
that's where you're going with this okay
i got it i see where you are you know
the the
greatest words in business required
to fly on a private jet if you could get
that into your contract if you're
anybody no i don't think it gets any
better than that by the way so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you